[la musique]
Hmm
A partir du 11 mars
Hummm
Bon environ un mois
les dents
Sortir à la mer qui jamais pour toujours
ce
Avec ma mère
Je n'ai pas pu trouver la femme de mon frère
tous les jours
Sortez terriblement à la mer dans cette station
Après je vais faire ça
[la musique]
Après environ 3 semaines
Sur la mer
Trouvez votre propre maison flottante
Mais si tu regardes près d'elle
Parce que cette mère et cette belle-fille peuvent être trouvées
[la musique]
Les plongeurs
Tate
Je les ai fait plonger là-bas
ce
Saga City Saga Si vous savez
Trouver une épouse avec le début
Trouvé sur la plage
je l'ai trouvé
Tout d'abord, Bluff est mort
Eh bien, nous sommes à nouveau ensemble
j'ai pu le faire
[la musique]
Eh bien, ça s'appelle la vie.
C'était bon
[la musique]
Je n'ai pas encore trouvé ma mère
À cause de cela, je veux toujours être bon ici.
Peut-être que c'est encore quelque part
Hmm
Peut-être même s'il n'a pas de forme, même s'il s'agit d'un seul os
je veux le trouver